Once one of the funniest men in Hollywood,
these days Vince Vaughn struggles to find
laughs on the big screen.
What got the star of Swingers and Wedding
Crashers stuck in a career rut?
Flops
Vaughn's Hollywood dry spell may have to do
with the fact that his last few movies have
tanked.
With dismal reviews, 2016's Unfinished Business—about
three coworkers who embark on a European business
trip gone terribly wrong—made headlines
for its shockingly low box-office returns.
According to Box Office Mojo, the film grossed
just $4.7 million in its opening weekend to
become the worst-performing major release
of Vaughn's career.
The fact that it finished its theatrical run
with about $10.2 million against a $35 million
budget only looked worse.
Unfinished Business followed four other flops:
The Internship, The Watch, The Dilemma, and
Delivery Man.
And only Delivery Man managed to earn a profit
on its domestic box office...and only because
it was so cheap to make in the first place.
Ouch.
True Defective
When Vaughn agreed to star in HBO's second
season of True Detective, he may have been
aware that his career was in a rut.
The show's critically acclaimed first season
was a highlight for Matthew McConaughey's
in 2013.
If it worked for him, it could work for Vaughn,
right?
Of course, now we know that True Detective
season two couldn't live up to its predecessor.
And Vaughn's performance didn't help much.
Whether he was threatening characters or reciting
one of the series' notorious monologues, he
looked out of place and out of his depth.
By the end of the season, it mainly served
to remind us that Vaughn is only fun to watch
when the laughs are intentional.
Casting Confusion
For years after Wedding Crashers, Vaughn struggled
to find his footing in Hollywood, often choosing
roles that felt very out of place.
There was the awkward attempt at becoming
a romantic leading man, like in 2006's The
Break-Up.
Two years later, Vaughn starred opposite Reese
Witherspoon in Four Christmases.
In both cases, Vaughn's style of humor didn't
match the rest of the movies.
Fans longed to see him in the dude-friendly
movies that made him popular.
What they got was Couples Retreat and Fred
Claus.
Ho ho no.
Getting older
When your career is defined by frat-boy movies
like Swingers, Old School, and Wedding Crashers,
eventually, you get too old to play those
parts.
Now in his 40s, Vaughn has officially entered
that territory.
The only time that he should be on a college
campus is to take one of his kids on a tour.
Speaking of...
Family man
Another reason he may not be a top dog in
Hollywood anymore?
Vaughn's actually been married to Canadian
realtor Kyla Weber for several years.
They have two children together: daughter
Locklyn and son Vernon.
It's possible that Vaughn has slowed his pace
to focus on being a husband and a dad.
After over 30 years in the business, he may
be tired of the grind.
Plus, with a reported net worth of $50 million,
he's not in danger of being unable to provide
for his family.
And maybe fatherhood will inspire his new
direction.
The right Pixar project may be all it takes
for a family-friendly version of Vince Vaughn
to mount the brilliant comeback we're all
waiting for.
It seems to be working for Owen Wilson...
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know how
you think Vince Vaughn can start swinging
again...